How is it we should
measure information
in a way that applies
to any communication
system you can think of?
Human, animal, or alien?
[CHIRPING]
Well, let's return to the late
19th century, where at the time
we were focused, as we
are today, on speed.
[PIANO MUSIC]
And one goal to
improve speed was
to design a machine which
allowed the operators to input
letters, which we can think
of as primary symbols,
and have the machine automate
the lower level signaling
events, such as
pulses of electricity,
what we can call
secondary symbols.
And machines can be driven
by some clock source,
allowing it to generate
a precise and rapid pulse
stream, which
presumably would run
much faster than any human hand.
And one great example of
this was the Baudot Multiplex
System.
And the design was put
into service in 1874.
And it built off the
same conceptual ideas
we've seen in the
shutter telegraph.
It consisted of five
keys, which could
be played in any combination.
Think of it as a chord.
Each combination would
represent a unique message.
With five notes, each
either on or off,
you can play 2 the power of
5, or 32 different chords.
The code assigned the
32 different chords
to each letter of the
alphabet, with the leftover
used for carriage returns,
new line, and spaces.
So the operator would
literally play letters,
and their machine
would automatically
output a pulse stream
representing the letters.
ANNOUNCER: Like this for letter
T. Or like this for letter R.
Or like this for letter B.
So we have an output signal
containing various combinations
of DC impulses, a signal that
accurately represents
the message
type from a teletypewriter.
NARRATOR: Behind the counter,
the mechanical nerves
of the system change
words to holes on tape,
and the holes on tape to
electrical impulses speeding
over the wires.
SPEAKER 1: Notice at the
lowest level, this system
is exchanging either
the presence or absence
of electrical current in a
sequence divided using a clock.
So, how fast can our
internal clocks run?
Well, the limiting
speed was not the clock.
Then and today, the
speed of transmission
was physically limited
by the minimum spaces
between these impulses,
or the pulse rate.
And this problem
plagued engineers
who were testing
underground submarine cables
using the existing
Morse code system.
And it's similar to an
echo, or a sustained note.
If one sends dots too fast
over a long undersea circuit,
they will run together
at the receiving end.
Because the symbol we
received at the far end
of the circuit will
be a slightly longer,
smoothed out rise and
fall, not an exact replica.
And sending pulses
too fast results
in inter-symbol interference.
This occurs, for example, when
the longer flow of a current
bleeds into the
next time division,
and perhaps reverses a 0 to a 1.
So even if we're
automating the detection
of these current levels,
there is a fundamental limit
to how far we can squeeze
two pulses together.
And this is the same
problem Alice and Bob ran
into with their string
communication system, which
we called the
maximum pluck speed.
If they plucked any faster
than two plucks per second,
they noticed they started
to bleed together,
and they got confused.
So this is called
the symbol rate.
Remember, a symbol
can be broadly defined
as the current state of
some observable signal which
persists for a fixed
period of time.
Whether you are using fire,
sound, electrical current,
anything, a signaling event
is simply a change from one
state to another.
So the symbol rate is the
number of signaling events which
can be squeezed
together in one second.
[BEEPING]